Chris even from a state away millions of
Nevada and shelling out millions of
dollars to watch Sunday's Super Bowl but
when it's in town next year business is
expecting an even bigger touchdown in
profit Ryan Matthew shows us the
potential impact
the big game anticipated to bring tens
of thousands of Spectators to the
stadium hundreds of thousands more to
the valley and to our local businesses
hundreds of millions of dollars I'm
assuming this was very busy over the
weekend absolutely the smallest of
Valley food trucks to the biggest of
strip restaurants get their supplies
from Standard Restaurant Supply we can
get it for you from the smallest
toothpicks to the biggest equipment
we've got it all Mike Spellman and
Catherine Justice save for them Super
Bowl 57 was a profit touchdown we're
right here so those last minute things
that anybody needs too as we get closer
to the Super Bowl is it's exciting
because we can help Las Vegas you were
now on the clock profit possibilities
when the game touches down in a year's
time this year the retail association of
Nevada predicting nearly 2 million
nevadans tuned in a collective spending
of 160 million dollars on the food TVs
furniture and team merchandise the
national retail Federation revealing
average spending per person for the day
nearly reached free pandemic levels this
year six months ago we were already
talking about oh yeah so now Las Vegas
businesses are ramping up preparations
they're already working with some of
their customers and we're already
working with our corporate office just
to kind of make sure that we're sitting
in a good spot come like fourth quarter
next year for a pricey spectacle that
could bring historic profits we're
hoping to see
double the profit for us you know which
at the very least would mean huge profit
for our local businesses our local
restaurants